Da haben wir sozusagen wieder die zwei Themen. Uwe, dir vielen Dank erst mal.
Ich führe, gerne.
Und viel Spaß noch. Und viel Glück beim Breitbandausbau. Man kommt bei diesen Themen nicht drum herum, das finde ich immer sehr spannend zu sagen. Man sagt also einerseits Breitbandausbau, das müsste mal politisch entschieden werden und so. Andererseits ist dann gleich wieder dieses Störerhaft. Wir müssen das glaube ich nochmal genau erklären. Das machen wir aber gleich. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio auf Fritz im Blue Moon. Es ist ein letzter Donnerstag im Monat. Da findet es statt, dass der Chaos Computer Club hier in die Studios kommt und Dinge erzählt, die mit dem Internet zu tun haben. Heute geht es um Netzpolitik, also um genau was ist denn das eigentlich und wie macht man das und was bringt man das überhaupt alles? Und zu Gast ist Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und guten Tag. Hallo. Auch vom Blog Netzpolitik Org und da ist auch Florian Gilberg da. Hallo und guten Tag. Moin Moin. Und wir wollen mit euch darüber reden, was ist Netzpolitik und welche Rolle spielt es in eurem Leben? Und dazu könnt ihr Folgendes tun. Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Und weil wir schon, wir haben schon ein bisschen über die Schwierigkeit gesprochen, dass es bestimmte Dinge in Netzpolitik gibt, die an die Politiker heranzutragen, ganz schön schwierig ist, dass es ganz viele verschiedene Themen ist. Und interessanterweise ist in dieser Sendung ein Thema ganz euch sehr wichtig, was normalerweise in der Debatte nicht so die große Rolle spielt, weil da geht es dann dann meistens um Vorratsarten, Speicherung und Geheimdienstüberwachung und die ganzen schlimmen Dinge. Und heute geht es hier so vor allem um Breitbandausbau. Wenn das ein Thema ist, das euch auch interessiert, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Aber wenn ihr ein anderes Thema wollt, könnt ihr es natürlich auch gerne tun, weil Netzpolitik ist ja ein weites Feld. Und wir hatten gerade Uwe dran, der sagte, naja, das mit dem Breitbandausbau, da würde er von Netzpolitik schon erwarten, dass da geklärt wird, das ist halt ein Menschenrecht, kann man das so sagen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß. Daseinsvorsorge heißt das Wort, also das sollte schon der Staatssichtum kümmern, dass wirklich jeder darauf Anspruch hat und das auch aufgeführt wird. Klaus hat auch noch angerufen aus dem Friedrichshain, du würdest auch noch was sagen. Hallo Klaus.
Oh, äh, mal ne Frage, für welche Agentur arbeitet denn die letzte Dame da im Hintergrund?
Bitte was?
Hast du gemerkt, sie den Anruf angenommen hat?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht, das war Fritz. Ich meine die andere Dame, die im Hintergrund sprechen tut.
Die andere Dame, Klaus, sind wir ein bisschen verwirrt? Oder bin ich jetzt in der Dame?
Ja, die von der Partei.
Wir haben hier keine Dame von einer Partei, wir haben hier Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club.
Die von Chaos Computer Club.
Genau, die ist parteilos.
Nee, dummig nicht.
Sondern?
Weil ich denke mal, dass du für den Rosariesen arbeiten tust.
Für den Telekom? Ach du meine Güte, nein.
Klaus, die Sendung ist nur zwei Stunden lang und für Verschwörungstheorien haben wir wirklich wenig Zeit. Doch, das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Warum will der Rosariese die Netzneutralität aufheben?
Na ich denke, der Konzern hat einfach wirtschaftliche Interessen.
Kann jetzt bitte einer von euch noch mal in einfachen Worten erklären, was Netzneutralität ist?
Also es geht bei Netzneutralität um die Frage. Wer darf aus welchen Gründen Datenpakete priorisieren oder aber auch blockieren?
In einfachen Worten.
Behindern, beschleunigen? Also die Frage, wer darf und aus welchen Gründen? Oh was?
So ich möchte Klaus noch mal kurz herunterziehen, um mit der Netzneutralität, Herrgott, weil das immer wieder fällt, das Wort noch mal genauer zu erklären. Es geht darum, wenn man nicht vom einzelnen Datenpaket spricht, sondern sozusagen generell als User, wie man das wahrnimmt, ist es so, dass bestimmte Dienste bevorzugt werden können. Also Telekom User kennen das vielleicht, YouTube Videos gucken ist echt schwierig. Aus eigener Erfahrung weiß ich, dass es einfacher ist, sich ein Netzwerk noch zu klicken, wo man in Großbritannien surft, weil dann die YouTube Videos schneller kommen, weil die Telekom sich auf die Reihe kriegt. Umgedreht würde Netzneutralität bedeuten, als die Telekom sagt, also YouTube ist sehr schnell, aber du musst dann ein bisschen extra bezahlen, beziehungsweise andere Dienste sind leichter. Also es gäbe dann nicht mehr, alles wird gleichzeitig durchs Internet gequetscht, sondern man könnte gewisse Dinge bevorzugen, oder was Florian auch vorhin sagte, deine Internettraffic, deine Bandbreite wird gedrosselt, aber bestimmte Dienste darfst du trotzdem benutzen.
Und zwar geben nach dem Inhalt, also entschieden wird, was schneller durch die Leitung geht, je nach Inhalt. Und das ist ja sozusagen die entscheidende Frage, also gucke ich an, was ist das für ein Datenpaket oder behandel ich alle gleich?
Ganz genau, das ist eben das Ding, was auch so oft zu kurz kommt, um das eben machen zu können und in einer Welt, wo man eben dann so Datenpakete unterschiedlich schnell oder langsam zustellt, muss man eben die Pakete quasi aufschnüllen und reingucken, was ich denn da gerade mir eigentlich angucken möchte.
Also sozusagen nicht nur kein gleichberechtigtes Internet mehr, sondern es ist auch noch, dass man dazu den gesamten Datenverkehr entschlüsseln und mitschnüffeln muss quasi. So jetzt hätten wir das geklärt. Klaus, jetzt nochmal, was war deine Frage eigentlich?
Aber warum will die Telekom, also der rosa Riese, die Netzwerkstellen in den Außenbezirken abkapseln, dass die netzneutralen Anbieter nicht mehr hinkommen?
Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, worauf du hinaus willst. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Also geht es dir darum zu wissen, warum die Telekom gegen Netzneutralität ist oder?
Wenn die Telekom dagegen ist, dann einfach nur, weil sie mehr Geld machen kann, wenn in Zukunft keine Netzneutralität mehr gibt. Na ja klar. Und die sind ja selber auch Inhalteanbieter. Also die Telekom zum Beispiel, wenn wir an die WM denken oder so. Und für die ist es schlicht, ein neues Geschäftsfeld wird sie aufmachen können, wenn sie bestimmte Daten schneller durchlassen. Und wenn sie das vor allen Dingen dürfen, das ist ja eine gesetzliche Frage, ob man das darf und in welcher Art man das darf. Und die Debatte haben wir halt nicht nur für die Telekom, sondern wir haben sie auch gleich noch in Europa. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass das nicht nur bei uns debattiert wird, das gibt es ja nicht nur bei Telekom, sondern natürlich auch in Europa. Und da nun mal ein Großteil dieser Festnetzkunden immer noch bei Telekom sind, ist ja ein alter Staatskonzern, ist natürlich die Entscheidung der Telekom für viele Menschen, die da kunden sind wichtig, weil eben der größte Anbieter ist im Festnetzbereich und die machen eine ganz gute Lobbyarbeit. Die versuchen natürlich ihre geschäftlichen Interessen durchzusetzen. Zum Beispiel.
Gut, hätten wir das geklärt. Vielen Dank Klaus und jetzt nochmal zu der Netzneutralitätsdebatte. Welche Positionen habt ihr da und wie versucht ihr die umzusetzen?
Also bei dem Chaos Computer Club ist ganz klar diese Informations- und Meinungsfreiheit wichtig. Denn Netzneutralität dreht sich ja eigentlich längst nicht nur um geschäftliche Fragen, sondern auch immer um die Frage, wer darf sich von wem informieren lassen. Also wer kann zum Beispiel alles, was er am Markt gemacht hat, seine Inhalte schneller an den Mann bringen. Also ist tatsächlich diese kleine Blog noch genauso schnell zu klicken, wie eine bekannte Newsseite mit vier Werbung, die vielleicht zu einem großen Konzern gehört. Kann ich zum Beispiel ein kleines Geschäft haben, was ich nicht auch, ein Videokanal hat, die selben Geschwindigkeiten haben, wie etwa jemand, der bei YouTube ein Video anguckt. Und es ist für uns eher auch eine politische Frage und auch letztlich wieder eine technische. Denn wie kann man denn so eine Netznotalität brechen? Welche Technik braucht man denn, wenn man solche Filterungen, ja, Priorisierungen, wenn man die durchsetzen will? Denn da ist gleichzeitig immer die Frage dabei, jemand muss in diese Datenpakete reingucken, um den Inhalt zu bestimmen, den er priorisieren will oder blockieren will. Und da ist eine imminent politische Frage, ob jemand während der Verkehr durch seine Infrastruktur läuft, in die Datenpakete hineinsieht und dann eben die Weiche nach links oder nach rechts stellt. Das heißt, so richtig menschenrechtliche Fragen, also Meinungs- und Informationsfreiheit sind ja in der hohen Rechte.
Ganz genau, da wollte ich auch noch gerade anknüpfen. Also auch von Nutzerseite ist es ja extrem wichtig, auch sage ich jetzt mal von unserer Sicht von netzpolitik.org, dass man eben Chancengleichheit gewährleistet, dass wenn wir alle dann irgendwann nur noch den ganz langsam gedrosselten 64 Kilobit Zugang zum Netz haben und dann eben draufzahlen müssen für alles, was wir zusätzlich machen müssen, also sage ich mal Monatspaket YouTube kostet noch mal 5 Euro mehr, wenn du Facebook benutzen willst kostet nochmal 10 Euro mehr und so weiter, dann wird die Zahl der Nutzer, die sich das Internet noch leisten können, sehr viel kleiner, aber die Wahrnehmung wird ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht geringer werden in der Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, es bestimmen immer weniger Leute, immer mehr die Themen und das Internet wird zu einem militären Medium und das ist absolut der falsche Weg.
Dann haben wir quasi so eine Art Fernsehen wieder mit wenigen Kanälen, die wir benutzen können oder zumindest man muss es sich leisten können, das ganze Internet zu erleben, das ist eine spannende Frage. So, jetzt haben wir jetzt auch noch einen spannenden Typen am Telefon, zwar Toni, der von sich sagt, der würde bei der Telekom arbeiten. Hallo und guten Abend Toni.
Grüß dich, hallo, grüße euch allesamt. Ja, also ihr könnt euch schon mal drauf einstellen, also die Telekom hat schon IPTV. Natürlich hat sie das, also ich meine, alle Telkurses, ich finde das irgendwie immer ein bisschen dämlich auf die Telekom raufzurun, weil eigentlich im Grunde alle Telkurses das gleiche wollen. Sie wollen eigentlich ein Internet haben, was eigentlich das ist, was wir vom klassischen Fernsehen kennen, das hätten sie am liebsten. Also heute wird mit den Services geworben, irgendwie, ich meine.
Die Telekom ist halt im Fokus, weil sie ein großer Anbieter ist. Und auch, weil sie dem Staat gehört, irgendwie sind wir quasi über den Stadtbesitzer der Telekom.
Ja, genau, und weil wir für 8, 50 Euro da sitzen. Ja, du lachst dich, weil das ist die weiche Flanke in der Netzpolitik, die soziale Flanke irgendwie in der Netzpolitik irgendwie sehr selten bedient wird. Das muss man dazu eigentlich auch sagen. Na, was ich damit meine ist tatsächlich, wenn man sich so anguckt, die großen Internetunternehmen, das sind ja nicht nur die Telekoms irgendwie, geh zu Amazon zum Beispiel, geh irgendwo anders hin, geh zu diesen großen Unternehmen, sie zahlen irgendwie für den Maschinenraum 8, 50 Euro in Deutschland, also wirklich den Mindestlohn, die zahlen für ihre großen Mitarbeiter sehr, sehr viel. Also es sind einfach klassisch international aufgestellte, große Unternehmen, die, ja, also ich meine, man muss sich angucken, wie zum Beispiel Google und Facebook irgendwie in San Francisco die Gentrifizierung irgendwie vorantreibend mit macht.
Okay, warte, Toni, Toni, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, nicht überall hin, nochmal ganz von vorne. Du arbeitest bei der Telekom?
Ich arbeite im 2nd Level bei der Telekom, genau. Das ist da, wenn du zum Beispiel ankommst und sagst irgendwie du hast Probleme mit deinem Entertain und so und dann kommst du erstmal nicht zu mir, sondern dann kommst du zu jemanden, der versucht das so zu lösen und wenn es im Router Neustart nicht klappt, dann darf ich ran.
Okay, verstehe. So und jetzt zur Netzneutralität.
Genau und das Problem ist, du merkst immer mehr, dass sie abdriften, sie wollen immer mehr für ihre Services Geld haben, sie möchten am liebsten, ja, dass du für jeden Furz eigentlich zahlst. Also egal was du machst irgendwie, du, also mein Raum ist natürlich, es fällt IP aus meiner Dose, am liebsten irgendwie ein 100 MBit Anschluss, ja. Das wird irgendwie in Zukunft so wie das aussieht nicht sein, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Sie werden irgendwie auf irgendwelche Services aufsetzen. Wenn du was haben willst, musst du dafür zahlen. Also das ist manchmal schon eine Lächerlichkeit, wo du manchmal denkst so ja, okay, also früher konntest du den Leuten noch ein Outlook einrichten, dafür sollen wir heute 5 Euro im Monat zahlen. Das sind so kleine, einfache Sachen, aber das ist...
Meinst du jetzt konkret bei dir jetzt auch der Job, den du machst, also das als Serviceleistung?
Als Beispiel, aber sie wollen natürlich auch für Netzleistungen irgendwie, dass du Geld zahlst, sei es das Fernsehen. Ich bin sicher, also die Telekom hat schon angefangen bei T-Mobile zum Beispiel, hier dieser Tarif, wo du irgendwie für Spotify extra irgendwie nicht, du hast ein bisschen mehr gezahlt, dafür wurde Spotify nicht aufs Volumen angerechnet. Das fand ich schon eine ziemlich grobe Verletzung.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz klar.
Das wird auch im Festnetz kommen, da bin ich mir sicher, dass sie anbieten werden.
Jetzt bist du aber schon so ein bisschen fatalistisch, glaubst du also das gar nicht mehr zu ändern?
Ach man, ich bin immer auf Notze irgendwie, ich hab schon einfach genug gesehen und du hast vorhin selber gesagt, du hast auch recht irgendwie, ich bin doch groß geworden, da haben sich die Leute noch aufgeregt, dass Christian Schwartzscheligen irgendwie Kupfer hat verlegen lassen damals, falls du dich erinnerst, ja und kein Glasfaser sozusagen fürs Kabelfernsehen und es rauskam, dass irgendwie sein Schwager so eine Kupferfabrik gehört hat, ja so eine Kabelfabrik.
Damals schon, ja.
Heute wär ich mir nicht so sicher, muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen, ja. Also die Zeiten haben sich einfach geändert, also ich auch, wenn man sich also wenn man sich wenn man sich anguckt, wie Europapolitik betrieben wird, die die Leute von der Industrie sitzen an Stellen, man fühlt sich einfach, also das ist eben sehr fatalistisch. Ich geh zu, man fühlt sich tatsächlich total machtlos. Wie hättest du es denn gerne? Wie ich es gerne hätte, ich hätte gerne tatsächlich irgendwie die Infrastruktur, egal ob das jetzt Internet ist oder Wasser oder Strom, tatsächlich in öffentlicher Hand. Also das muss ich dazu ganz einfach sagen.
Boah krass, wirst du überhaupt wieder Staatsbeamter?
Nein, das hat mit Staatsbeamter nichts zu tun. Ich denke öffentliche Infrastruktur ist eine Sache, von der jeder profitieren muss, auf eine Art und Weise.
Ich habe durchaus verstanden, das war die Forderung, das war jetzt ein bisschen schranzhaft.
Ich finde persönlich, Infrastruktur ist keine Sache, die abhängig sein muss vom Geldbeutel. Und ich meine, in Deutschland haben wir sogar noch eine Situation im Verhältnis zu anderen Ländern, wo mittlerweile schon Wasser in private Hände gegangen ist, wo es noch verhältnismäßig gut ist. Und ich denke aber, wir sehen tatsächlich in anderen Ländern, wo Leute sich schon Wasser nicht mehr leisten können, schon fast eigentlich unsere Zukunft irgendwie blinken auf eine Art und Weise. Das ist sehr fatalistisch, ich gebe es zu.
Aber warum können wir das politisch nicht auch erreichen? Also ich meine, das kann man doch als Forderung formulieren, nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, ich gucke mich auf meine Arbeit um, ich sehe irgendwie unsere ganzen Mindestlöhner, wie wir alle rumstreunen. Ja, ich weiß, ich wähle und ich wähle sehr links irgendwie, nicht wie seit Jahren links. Wie du siehst, hilft das seit, jetzt bin ich 47, wie lange darf ich wählen? Und seitdem hilft das nichts, ja, stimmt, das hilft wenig.
Och, jetzt macht es uns aber jetzt total, jetzt geht es nicht.
Ich mach euch nicht runter, nein.
So, jetzt Toni, letzte Frage, du arbeitest bei einem Konzern, mit dessen Politik du nicht so einverstanden bist.
Warum?
Hast du schon mal versucht, wenn du mal krank geworden bist, keinen Abschluss hast, irgendwie eine Arbeit zu kriegen, dann bist du froh, wenn du irgendwo einen Job kriegst. Das ist immer das Problem. Du guckst dich bei uns auf Arbeit um, es arbeiten total viele verschiedene Leute bei uns. Es sind viele Leute, die gestrauchelt sind, auch viele Leute, die krank geworden sind, viele Leute, die älter sind. Ja, das ist einfach manchmal so.
Also, du musst dich mit der Politik des Konzernes ja nicht gleich machen, nur weil du da arbeitest.
Also, das denk ich auch.
Aber meinst du, dass du Ärger kriegen konntest, wenn dein Chef das hier hört?
Nein, ich glaube auch nicht, dass mein Chef sich das anhört.
Schade eigentlich, oder?
Ja, vielleicht sollten die Chefs das mal hören.
Deswegen muss man Netzpolitik machen, da redet man auch mal mit den Chefs.
Toni, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
So, das ist ja auch sehr missant. Das ist natürlich auch so eine schwierige Frage. Und das, gerade was Toni jetzt gesagt hat, man ist halt manchmal gezwungen bei der Firma zu arbeiten, wo man halt gar nicht übereinschätzt. Also das liebe Geld ist dann halt auch auf ganz anderer Ebene.
Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, glaube ich, für Markus. Eingangsfrage, Markus fragte ja so am Anfang, warum sich eigentlich so wenige engagieren. Man muss sich schon klar machen, auch wenn man selber jetzt, zumindest für mich selbst kann ich jetzt sagen, Netzpolitik natürlich sehr wichtig finde, so ein Zukunftsthema, dass viele Leute ganz andere Sorgen haben, um die sie sich jeden Tag kümmern müssen. Das ist immer so ein bisschen der Vorwurf, ja, ihr engagiert euch zu wenig, natürlich für manche Leute einfach auch nicht zutrifft, weil die ganz andere Sorgen haben. Wir müssen sich irgendwie auf Wasser halten oder so.
Also krass formuliert, Netzpolitik ist schon ein Luxusproblem.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht mehr. Dafür ist das Politikfeld zu breit und dafür interessieren sich auch zu viele Leute dafür. Auch zu viele Politiker übrigens. Also damit das Feld ist nicht mehr so ein Nischen politisches Feld und das hat auch mittlerweile viele soziale Fragen, die damit hineinspielen. Gerade beim Breitband und dieser Daseinsvorsorge ist das ja schon bei. Aber auch bei anderen netzpolitischen Fragen. Also etwa Beteiligung, das ist ja auch nur soziale Frage.
Also sagen, die hinterstehende Idee ist, man muss dafür sorgen, dass die Leute online kommen, weil wenn man das nicht macht, hängt man diese Leute von der politischen Willensbildung ab, oder?
Sicher auch bei Netzneutralität. Also soll nicht vom Geld abhängen, ob ich mich unabhängig informieren kann. Also es sind schon immer auch Fragen bei, die breiter sind, die eine ganze Gesellschaft betreffen. Vor allen Dingen aber in Zukunft auf jeden Fall betreffen werden.
Ich würde jetzt gerne noch zu dem Thema zurückkommen, was wir relativ weit vorne schon angesprochen hatten, nämlich das mit der Politik. Wir hatten ja schon festgestellt, die Hauptentscheidungen werden immer getroffen von den Machtpolitikern, die dann wiederum beraten werden. Aber ist denn das so, dass man Parteien eindeutig Netzpositionen zuordnen kann? Weil es ist doch jetzt auch so, dass auch die großen Parteien sozusagen Netzverbände und vereinzelt blickt da auch Kompetenz durch. Wie ist denn das?
Die Politik hat es halt extrem in den letzten Jahren entdeckt. Ich meine, wir haben ja auch seit der letzten Bundestagswahl gab es ja auch groß angekündigt, die digitale Agenda und im Kollektionsvertrag verankert. Und alles sollte viel besser werden. Die IT-Sicherheit sollte ausgebaut werden. Und wir steuern in eine rosige Zukunft. Und heute stehen wir irgendwie dann trotzdem noch da. Und es ist irgendwie wenig passiert. Aber ja, wie du gerade schon meintest, es gibt halt schon Verbände auch innerhalb der Parteien, denen man das jetzt gar nicht mal so als Kernkompetenz zurechnen würde, wo sehr gute Leute auch sind und arbeiten und da durchaus was machen. Aber die dann halt trotzdem vielleicht oftmals durch die klare Parteilinie daran gehindert würden, sich dann aber auch anders organisieren.
Also oft sind es natürlich auch so gegenteilige Interessen, die gegeneinander abgewogen werden müssen. Freiheit und Sicherheit zum Beispiel ganz oft. Natürlich gibt es in allen Parteien mittlerweile ein oder mehrere Fachpolitiker und netzpolitische Sprecher natürlich mittlerweile. Also klar, jeder kennt, die Bundeskanzlerin äußert sich ab und an zur Netzpolitik. Wir haben die netzpolitischen Sprechrunden, die der Innenminister schon mal eingeäutet hatte. Da ist schon was passiert.
Es gibt auch innerhalb von Parteien sozusagen gegensätzliche Meinungen.
Es ist natürlich auch in allen Politikverhältnissen.
Also gibt es CSU-Politiker, die gegen die Vorzeihansprechung sind?
Ja, natürlich. Es sind aber nicht die Schwitzenpolitiker.
Und dann halt die Frage, woher kommt das? Also das scheint ja so, als ob sie sagen, also ich verstehe nicht, wie das dann sein kann. Also wenn man denken würde, es geht um inhaltliche Argumente, also nur um inhaltliche Argumente, dann müsste es ja eine klare Haltung geben.
Ja, aber ich glaube, jeder weiß, dass in der Politik inhaltliche Sachfragen nun nicht immer die entscheidende Rolle spielen. Also in gewisser Verständnis habe ich dafür auch. Also man muss sich überlegen, ja, wie sieht denn der Bundestag, da sind viele Leute, es gibt viele viele Themen und nicht jeder weiß überall Bescheid. Und in der Regel gibt es eine Fraktionslinie. Und das Abstimmungsverhalten ist entsprechend, da gibt es auch keine Abweichung.
Wodurch wird sie denn festgelegt? Und vor allen Dingen, wieso kann sie sich von den Fachlauten unterscheiden?
Na, es gibt natürlich erstmal gegensätzlich politische Meinungen. Wir nehmen mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder wir können das auch bei Netzneutralität machen oder beim Datenschutz. Es gibt eine Konservativ-Behaltung. Klar, will man oder will man nicht. Damit bedient man aber auch Wähler. Man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass sich das genauso in der Wahlbevölkerung abbildet. Es gibt einen Anteil der Deutschen, die möchte diese anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Zumindest schreckt es sie nicht vom VN ab.
Aber das hört sich so an, als ob die Netzpolitik stellenweise so gemacht wird, dass da nur die Haltung draufgeklatscht wird, die zum jeweiligen Label der Partei passt und dass es nicht um Sachargumente geht.
Doch, das ist häufig so. Klar, wurde ein Label daran geklebt. Als die FDP noch im Bundestag war, hat man eine typische freiheitliche Position gesehen, die keine Vorratszeitenspeicherung hat. Die hat die damalige Staatsministerin vertreten. Und die Konservativen haben gesagt, die versprechen damit Sicherheit, also wollen wir das auch haben. Und generell auch eine wirtschaftsfreundlichere Position, die in der Regel von den Konservativen vertreten wird. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Klassiker.
Aber jetzt, als ihr wiederum die Frage an euch als Aktivisten, wenn man jetzt sozusagen weiß, es geht eigentlich in großen Teilen gar nicht um die inhaltliche Argumentation zu dem Thema, sondern da wird einfach eine Haltung tradiert. Wie arbeitet man damit? Oder sagt man dann einfach so, es macht halt eh keinen Sinn, mit der und der Partei zu sprechen, weil man die gar nicht überzeugen kann, weil es da nicht um inhaltliche Dinge geht?
Man muss halt nicht an der Parteiebene ein bisschen ansetzen, sondern wie du auch gerade schon meintest, es gibt ja die Strömungen und die Leute in Parteien und ich meine, die nächste Wahl kommt halt bestimmt und wer weiß, wie die Machtverhältnisse dann aussehen. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass sich die Leute dann auch da anders zusammenschließen oder gucken wir zum Beispiel auf europäische Ebene, wo sich Leute auch in anderen Fraktionen, als es auf Bundesebene der Fall ist, dann zusammenschließen und da können dann ja auch ganz andere Machtverhältnisse entstehen.
Also ich glaube, es sind auch mehrere Ebenen. Das eine ist, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auf Netzpolitik org blickt, da geht es ja viel auch um Information. Also Sachen erklären. Beim CCC ist es auch häufig so, dass wir, wenn jetzt nicht gerade Wahlkampf ist, eigentlich mit allen Parteien sprechen. Ich glaube, außer den Nazis. Ich glaube, es nutzt immer, ein sachliches Gespräch zu führen. Denn der Informationsbedarf ist vielfach da. Wir werden im CCC auch einfach häufig gefragt, zum Beispiel, was die Themen sind, die wir für zukünftig besonders wichtig halten. Es gibt schon Informationsbedarf. Es gibt auch in der Politik den Bedarf, sich gerade kommerziell unabhängig informieren lassen zu wollen. Der ist schon da. Klar, das erlebe ich auch relativ häufig. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch die Gegenöffentlichkeit, die man versuchen muss herzustellen, wo zum Beispiel netzpolitik.org ein Mittel ist, wo aber auch viele NGOs in diesem Bereich Kampagnen fahren und einfach viel erklären, eine Gegenöffentlichkeit bilden. Weil natürlich Wirtschaftsinteressen in den Zeitungen relativ gut abgebildet werden, weil die eine ordentliche PR machen.
Ich bin an dieser einen Stelle hängen geblieben, wo du gesagt hast, okay, mit allen Parteien sprechen, weil sach die Information ist auch wichtig. Aber ist das nicht erstens super frustrierend, zu einer Partei zu gehen, wo man jetzt schon vorher weiß, die werden trotzdem ihre Meinung nicht ändern? Und läuft man nicht vielleicht sogar an Gefahr, dass man als Schmuckblatt verwendet wird? Also wenn die sagen, eine Partei, die für die Vorwarnzeit schon bei sich ist, dann kann man sagen, ha ha, wir haben ja auch mit dem CCC gesprochen. Aber trotzdem ist es nicht kontraproduktiv für das öffentliche Bild?
Na ja, sind ja zwei sehr unterschiedliche Fragen. Eine ist natürlich frustrierend, manchmal, wenn man bemerkt, dass Sachargumente, die man bringt, manchmal auch technisch zwingende Argumente, gibt es ja auch, überhaupt nicht beachtet werden. Oder dass man zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Stellungnahme abgibt, eigentlich schon an einem Punkt im Gesetzgebungsverfahren ist, wo man genau weiß, die haben ihre Meinung schon gebildet. Und selbst wenn man manchmal in Ausschüssen sitzt, oder so im Bundestag, wo die Gesetze gemacht werden, und merkt, eigentlich sind alle Sachverständige, nicht nur man selbst, als CCC, wenn da ein Vertreter sitzt, sondern auch die anderen, zum Beispiel auch die Juristen oder andere Techniker dagegen, das frustriert. Aber andererseits, wenn man ein bisschen langfristig guckt, habe ich oft den Eindruck, dass in netzpolitischen Themen steht der Tropfen, den Stein schon höht. Es gibt einen Streit über zehn Jahre über die Vorzeitsprechung und die Argumentation hat sich schon verändert. Und manche Argumente können nicht mehr wegdiskutiert werden. Also die politische Argumentation ändert sich. Und bei manchen Sachen, da merkt man, okay, die Schlacht ist irgendwie nicht zu gewinnen. Und bei anderen schafft man den. Und manchmal muss man einen langen Atem haben. Bei der zweiten Frage ist es, diese Feigenblatt, also nutzen die einen selbst. Darüber streiten wir uns oft. Deswegen, also im TTC ist es so. Das sind Wahlkampfzeiten, da halten wir uns ein bisschen stärker fern von Parteien, weil wir eben nicht, wir wollen da nicht vereinnahmt werden. Andererseits ist es natürlich auch im Wahlkampfzeiten manchmal ganz schön wichtig, dass man versucht, diese Position abzuklopfen und auch klar zu machen, dass man zum Beispiel danach guckt, was nach der Wahl ist. Dass man nicht nur Wahlprogramme liest, sondern auch guckt, ob die die später umsetzen. Und was eigentlich dann im Koalitionsvertrag steht. Also das ist ein schwieriger Grad. Und natürlich hängt es letztlich auch von diesen Netzpolitikern, Fachpolitikern an. Manche sind einfach echt sympathisch und zugänglich, hören zu. Und manche sind einfach arrogante Leute, mit denen man eigentlich nach einer Weile nichts mehr zu tun haben will. Das ist ja auch manchmal die Nette oder nicht. Und dann natürlich auch die Macht, die die in einer eigenen Partei haben. Ist es jemand, der das schafft, sich auch Mehrheiten zu organisieren? Oder vielleicht sogar einen Parteitagsbeschluss? Oder ist das eh so ein Hinterbänkler? Das fragt man sich natürlich.
Du musst halt schon auch priorisieren. Die wollte ich gerade sagen. Gibt es ein Thema, das du aufgegeben hast?
Für mich persönlich ja. Es gibt Themen, wo ich mich persönlich nicht mehr engagiere, weil ich einfach hinterherweige, weil ich es lange getan habe. Oder weil ich glaube, das gewonnen oder verloren. Für den CCC würde ich es aber dennoch tun. Ich bin ja eine Weile in gewisser Weise auch ein Sprachrohr. Und ich glaube auch bei Netzpolitik ist es so ähnlich. Da werden auch manchmal Themen abgebildet, wo man jetzt nicht gleich die große Kampagne plant, also in der Redaktionsarbeit. Im CCC gibt es Sachen, die ich derzeit für gewonnen erachte. Das ist etwa die Debatte um Wahlcomputer. Da werden wir in den nächsten paar Jahren noch Ruhe haben. Das wird wiederkommen, nämlich in Form von Onlinewahlen. Aber so derzeit verfolge ich nicht mehr großartig, nur noch mehr aus so akademischem Interesse. Aber ich persönlich kann mich heute auch nicht mehr so stark beim Urheberrecht einbringen. Das war für mich ein ganz langer Thema. Aber das überlasse ich dann eben anderen. Da gibt es Gott sei Dank CCC genug, die sich dafür interessieren. Und Netzpolitik Org ist zum Beispiel auch gut vertreten. Aber da kann ich mich persönlich nicht mehr einbringen. Da habe ich den Eindruck, schon so oft in Diskussionen gesessen zu haben. Einfach auch schon so lange. Und ich kann auch ehrlich gesagt dann diese Debatten dann nicht mehr... Aber das sollte man auch nicht. Man muss ja auch Herzblut haben, eh jedenfalls, für Sachen. Und wenn ich merke, da bin ich jetzt überdrössig, dann wende ich mich anderen Themen zu. Das ist ja die Netzpolitik.
Also Netzpolitik ist nicht nur komplex, sondern auch kräftezehrend. Und wir haben noch gleich noch eine halbe Stunde. In der möchte ich über etwas sprechen, was jetzt immer wieder zwischendurch so ganz kurz auftauchte. Das war nämlich das Wort Europa. Was das mit Netzpolitik zu tun hat, das klären wir gleich. Aber erst gibt es die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Manche denken, sie haben es geschafft, wenn sie ihr eigenes Flugzeug haben. Oder ihre eigene Insel. Er, mein Name ist Casper, hat sein eigenes Festival. Fritz präsentiert Casper's Festival. Natürlich mit Casper, aber auch Prinz Porno. Und das Line-Up ist noch nicht komplett. Wer noch dazu kommt, bleibt spannend. Live von Obenmeer in der Wohlheide.
Um kurz nach halb 12.
Fritz, Nachrichten.
Mit Emily Ulbericht.
In Düsseldorf ist am Nachmittag die Wohnung des Co-Piloten der abgestürzten German Wings Maschine durchsucht worden. Die Ermittler hoffen, Hinweise auf sein Motiv zu bekommen. Der 27-Jährige soll die Maschine vorgestern absichtlich zum Absturz gebracht haben, als der Kapitän das Cockpit kurz verließ. Air Berlin, EasyJet und mehrere andere Fluggesellschaften haben inzwischen festgelegt, dass kein Pilot mehr allein im Cockpit bleiben darf. Bei der Lufthansa ist man geschoppt über die neue Entwicklung beim Flugzeugunglück. Lufthansa-Chef Spohr sagte am Nachmittag, was passiert sei, mache ihn fassungslos. Gleichzeitig sprach er von einem tragischen Einzelfall und betonte, dass er volles Vertrauen in seine Piloten habe. Das Cockpit-Personal werde bei Lufthansa sehr sorgfältig ausgewählt. Laut Spohr wurde bei dem 27-Jährigen nichts Auffälliges festgestellt. An vielen Berliner Schulen ist heute Unterricht ausgefallen. Auch einige Prüfungen mussten verschoben werden. Schuld war ein Warnstreik der Angestellten Lehrer. Sie gingen am Mittag für eine bessere Bezahlung auf die Straße. Aus Brandenburg kamen etwa 500 Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zur Demo nach Berlin. Und zum Sport-Basketball-Pokalsieger Alba Berlin darf weiter auf die Teilnahme an den Playoffs in der EuroLeague hoffen. Die Albatrosse gewannen am Abend gegen den serbischen Vizemeister Roter Stern Belgrad mit 73 zu 68. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Schöneberg 5 und in Treptow 6 Grad, in Frankfurt Oder und Brück 6 und in Prenzler und Neuropin 5 Grad. In der Nacht ist es weitgehend trocken bei 5 bis 3 Grad, morgen bleibt es kühl bei 8 bis 12 Grad. Dazu wieder viele Wolken und ab und zu auch Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, Stadtring Richtung Neukölln. Die Einfahrt Siemensdamm ist wegen Reparaturarbeiten gesperrt. A111, Stadtautobahn statt auswärts. Zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdamm und Schulzendorfer Straße ist die Straße wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Das Ganze noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Charlottenburg Masurenallee zwischen Theodor-Häusplatz und Messe-Damm gibt es Behinderungen wegen der Echo-Verleihung. Das Ganze auch noch bis morgen früh 5 Uhr. Und Mitte, die Invalidenstraße ist zwischen Gartenstraße und Caroline-Michele-Straße wegen Bauarbeiten in Richtung Moabit gesperrt. Und noch nach Brandenburg A9, Berlin Richtung Leipzig. Zwischen Beelitz und Brück gab es einen Unfall und es liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn und die rechte Spur ist gesperrt. Und A10, Berliner Ring, Dreieck Werder Richtung Dreieck Potsdam zwischen Dreieck Werder und Gelindo steht ein kaputter Laster auf dem Standstreifen. Allen unterwegs eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash.
Musikstreams Tschüss Das Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritzsee mit Markus Richter noch eine halbe Stunde und außerdem zu Gast Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Und Florian Gilberg vom Blog Netzpolitik.
Ich bin auch noch da, genau.
Das ist ja verrückt. So und wir haben über Netzpolitik gesprochen, die ersten anderthalbe Stunde und wir haben darüber gesprochen, wofür ihr euch bei Netzpolitik interessiert und das Thema, das euch am meisten interessiert, ist der Breitbandausbau, die Netzneutralität, also die Tatsache, wie viel Internet bei euch ankommt und wie frei ihr das benutzen dürft. Netzpolitik ist ziemlich komplex, man muss an die Politiker rankommen, man muss die Themen da irgendwie platzieren und es kann auch kräftezehrend sein. Und während der Sendung ist immer wieder gefallen und Europa, also Netzpolitik scheint nicht nur etwas deutsches zu sein, sondern auch vor allem in Europa stattzufinden vielleicht. Oder wie muss man das einschätzen? Welche Rolle spielt Europa in der Netzpolitik für uns jetzt konkret hier?
Man kann eigentlich sagen, wie in anderen Politikbereichen wird immer mehr nach Europa verlagert, kommt dann eine sogenannte Verordnung oder kommt eine Richtlinie, die bindet dann die Nationalstaaten. Wir haben das gesehen beim Datenschutz, wo das mal eine gute Sache sein kann oder eine schlechte Sache sein kann. Wir sehen das aber in eigentlich allen Bereichen beim Urheberrecht, da es eben versucht wird, ja, da Politik zu machen bei Netzneutralität. Und wir haben halt in Europa ein Problem mit einem Digitalkommissar, der Günther Oettinger heißt, ein absolut digital Unbeleckten zu haben. Er hat also auch klettermaßen überhaupt keinen Plan über Digitalien, wird aber wie immer von vielen Lobbyisten dabei beraten, wie man trotzdem Politik machen könnte. Also wir haben diese Problematik, dass wir eben nicht mehr nur über unser eigenes Land nachdenken müssen.
Aber, also bevor wir nochmal drüber reden, wie das dann in Europa ist mit der Netzpolitik, wie wird so jemand eigentlich Digitalkommissar, das ist ja nicht so, dass ein deutscher sozusagen Wirtschaftsminister ein Machtpolitiker ist, wie ihr am Anfang erklärt habt und kein Sachpolitiker, kann man sagen, naja gut, das ist ja aber auch so, also ich mein Wirtschaft ist jetzt auch ein so weites Feld, da gibt es halt eh keinen einzelnen Experten. Aber ein Digitalkommissar, das ist doch jemand mit einer ganz klar umrissenden Aufgabe.
Es ist aus mehreren Gründen, es ist schon ähnlich wie in der deutschen Politik, nur noch schlimmer. Denn man hat natürlich ein Länderpropos, dass bestimmte europäische Länder Kommissars Posten kriegen, aber man hatte vor allen Dingen diesen Örtigen, der mit irgendetwas abgespeist werden musste. Das ist ja so eine Art Dankes-Post und es hat überhaupt nichts mit Kompetenz zu tun. Das wird auch nicht so getan, als sei das so. Ja und es ist so erheitend, wie er über Netzpolitik redet, dass man wirklich, man kann Schmerzkrämpfe vor Lachen kriegen. Wir haben uns teilweise über die Reden. Das ist wirklich faszinierend.
Und auch was mit einer deutlichen Sprache da geredet wird. Also wir wurden auch erst vor zwei Wochen als Taliban bezahlt, weil wir uns für Netzpolitik konzentriert haben.
Wird der was?
Ja, wörtlich Talibanartig.
Er wirft uns eine Art oder allen, die sich in der Netzpolitik so einbringen, dieser sogenannten Netzgemeinde, nennt die auch so, so Extremismus vor in gewisser Weise. Das soll ja wohl dieser Vergleich bedeuten. Er hat auch total Vergleiche, wo man einfach merkt, er hat selbst mit dieser digitalen Welt gar nichts zu tun. Also Analogien, die nicht passen oder und dann kann er auch noch, also er kann es auch nicht ausdrücken. Er schafft es auch nicht, grammatikalisch korrekte Sätze zu bilden. Also seine Reden sind wirklich, vielleicht würdet ihr noch besser, aber seine Reden, die ersten, die waren wirklich, die waren eigentlich nur für Internethumor geeignet.
Okay, vielleicht ist das ja Absicht.
Was?
Na ja, Internethumor ist sozusagen ein großes Kommunikationsmittel und vielleicht will er sich sozusagen so einen Platz in der Netzgemeinschaft haben.
Schlau kalkuliert.
Das könnte durchaus sein. Aber jetzt sag mal, also in Europa werden sozusagen quasi die Vorgesetze für unsere Gesetze geschaffen, könnte man so sagen. Die gibt es so und die alle sagen ja Organisationen, die ich kenne, sozusagen also Netzpolitik, Chaos Computer Club und was es da alles noch gibt. Die sind ja, das sind ja deutsche Organisationen. Habt ihr dann auch noch, sagen Leute in Brüssel oder wie läuft das?
Also ich denke bei Netzpolitik war das, also als bevor es eigentlich richtig große Blog wurde, was auf hier gelesen wurde, schon immer eine gewisse Kooperation da, dass man mit anderen europäischen Bloggern damals noch oder mit Leuten in Brüssel geredet hat. Beim CCC, finde ich, waren wir relativ spät, uns auch europäisch steiger zu vernetzen. Denn es ist nicht so, wie du gerade gesagt hast, dass das so eine Vorgeletze sind. Es gibt natürlich insbesondere alle Verordnungen aus Brüssel, werden unmittelbar geltendes Recht hier in Deutschland. Also je nachdem, welche Art da beschlossen wird, kann das sofort gütig sein. Und ich glaube, der CCC hat das glaube ich eine Zeit lang nicht so gut gemacht, mit der Vernetzung ist aber deutlich besser geworden. Das ist vor allen Dingen natürlich auch aus meiner Sicht die Problematik, dass wir nicht wirklich eine europäische Öffentlichkeit haben. Man hat eben in den Zeitungen, liest man zwar bei Europa, aber auch aufgrund der Sprachbarriere, wird glaube ich immer noch sehr national gedacht. Das merkt man glaube ich bei manchen Debatten mehr, bei der Datenschutzdebatte vielleicht ein bisschen weniger. Da gibt es ja tatsächlich eine europäische Debatte.
Aber hat das dann sozusagen zur Auswirkung, dass die Politik nach Europa verlagert wird, aber da sind gar nicht die ganzen Netzaktivisten, dass dann da eher die unschönen Dinge besprochen und entschieden werden?
Naja, wir haben halt schon auch Netzaktivisten auf europäischer Ebene, aber ich meine, Brüssel wird ja nicht umsonst oft genug als Lobby-Hauptstadt der Welt so ein bisschen betitelt, wo ich weiß nicht die aktuelle Statistik, aber drei Lobbyisten auf einen abgeordneten ganz bestimmt kommen.
Hm, 3, 0 irgendwas auf jeden Abgeordneten. Ja, immer so ganz grob.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel die größte netzaktivistische Organisation, EDRI, die da sitzt und das sind aktuell zweieinhalb Stellen, die da versuchen, bürgerliche Positionen, netzaktivistische Positionen durchzusetzen. Und da sieht man ja schon ganz akut, wie chronisch unterbesetzt das alles ist und unterfinanziert auch.
Es gibt natürlich mittlerweile auch, wenn es um die Menschenrechte angeht, ein bisschen Professionell lobbying. Also wenn wir an sowas wie Endless International Denken oder Human Rights Watch, also große internationale Lobby-Organisationen, die zumindest ein paar Mann in Europa haben, das gibt es mittlerweile. Aber die waren natürlich deutlich später als die Wirtschaftsverbände, die diesen Schuss wie früher gehört haben und gemerkt haben, wo eigentlich die Gesetze gemacht werden und wo die Kohle sitzt.
Aber ist das sozusagen die fachfremden Nichtregierungsorganisationen, agieren die denn da in eurem Sinne oder haben die eigentlich ein anderes Thema und machen Netzpolitik so nebenbei?
Es kommt natürlich auch wieder auf die Organisationen an. Also Endless International hat zum Beispiel tatsächlich einige netzpolitische Themen, wo man sich freuen kann, weil die natürlich auch sehr gute Kampagnen machen und weil die sehr präsent sind in den Medien, auch international. Oder bei Human Rights Watch gibt es ein paar Ecken, die das betrifft. Netzpolitische Themen können ja durchaus mit den Menschenrechten zusammenfallen, also etwa in der Drohnendebatte, da gibt es ja durchaus ein paar Schnittmengen. Oder wenn man über Überwachungsfreiheit als Menschenrecht redet, wir haben ja auch eine europäische Menschenrechtskonvention, die uns zu sagen, diese Privatheitsfragen als Menschenrechtsfragen darlegen, da gibt es so Schnittmengen, aber die Arbeit zumindest, wenn man das so vergleicht von NGOs, EDI, also European Digital Rights, wo sich viele NGOs aus Europa zusammengeschlossen haben und MST oder Human Rights Watch arbeiten schon sehr unterschiedlich, denn da sind einfach andere, naja, Manpower MST ist, eine internationale Organisation und Human Rights Watch, die auch eine andere finanzielle Basis haben. Und in Deutschland sind traditionell diese NGOs, die sich da einsetzen, wie die Free Software Foundation oder eben auch der CCC, nicht mit viel Geld oder im CCC-Fall sogar ehrenamtlich tätig. Also da sind einfach wenige Menschen.
Das erinnert mich an eine spannende Frage, weil diese ganzen großen Organisationen, die haben ja auch ganz viele Spenden.
Genau, die finanzieren sich auch so.
Und das ist ja in Deutschland ist es ja eher nicht so, gerade bei Netzpolitik, da wird ja immer wieder um Spenden gebeten oder wird sogar aufgerufen. Irgendwie Sascha Lobo hat ja letztes Jahr auf der Republik noch mal extra einen Vortrag gehalten, mit mehr Geld in die Hand. Glaubt ihr, dass sich das irgendwie ändern wird, dass auch da eine Crowdfunding-Finanzierung im weitesten Sinne des Wortes mal an den Start kommen kann? Oder wird das ewig so bleiben, so unterbemittelt, könnte man sagen, unterbemittelt und ungeliebt?
Ich meine, in einigen Bereichen funktioniert das ja schon ganz gut, wir von netzpolitik.org sind zum Beispiel größtenteils Community finanziert. Wir finanzieren zum ganz kleinen Teil noch das Werbeanzeigen oder auch Stellenanzeigen, aber uns bezahlen quasi unsere Leser.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen eine ganz andere Größenordnung als sowas wie Amnesty International.
Ja, aber auch mit wenig Geld kann man da auch schon viel bewirken. Ich meine, natürlich, Sascha Lobo hat dann auch das Beispiel der Bikasini-Wars, glaube ich, angebracht, mit der Umweltbewegung, also mit einem Vogel in Bayern, der eben akut gefährdet ist und wo es, ich glaube, acht oder zehn Vollzeit-Lobbyisten quasi in dem Sinne gibt, die sich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigen, für diese Bikasini-Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen und eben Spenden zu akquirieren.
Ja, ein sehr plakatives Beispiel.
Ja, aber wenn es klappt, also wenn es funktioniert, das Beispiel.
Ja, hat auf jeden Fall anscheinend so gut funktioniert, dass wir auch einen klaren Anstieg an Spenden und an Unterstützungen danach verzeichnen konnten. Auch nochmal vielen Dank dafür an dieser Stelle, sag ich mal vom ganzen Team, denke ich mal. Aber es ist natürlich noch nicht aller Tage Abend. Und wir sind froh, dass das momentan so funktioniert, wie das weitergeht, wie die Zukunft zeigen wird.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, also ich meine, das hört sich jetzt sozusagen ganz positiv an, aber es ist, da wird halt ein, ich sage mal, mittelgroßes Block finanziert. Nicht Lobbyarbeit in der Politik, das ist ja der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus wollte. Während halt diese ganzen großen Organisationen halt tatsächlich dann dadurch Einfluss haben, dass es ist. Und dann sind wir wieder bei der Anfangsfrage, die Markus Becke dargestellt hat. Also sagen, warum interessieren sich so wenig Leute dafür? Und Interesse in diesem Fall vielleicht auch nur, keine Ahnung, halt da auch mal Geld zu geben.
Interesse muss ja auch nicht immer ein Geld sein. Kann ja auch als eigenes Engagement sein.
Aber hilft schon, oder?
Der Inhalt, ja klar. Also ich meine, also komm, wir sind ja hier nicht nur marktkonform. Aber ich beobachte natürlich gerade zum Beispiel im Vergleich mit den USA. Das ist eine andere Spendenkultur hier gibt. Also wenn ich die FF sehe, die Electronic Frontier Foundation und wie die sich in den USA finanziert oder eben auch die Großen eben wie Amnesty. Schon ein Unterschied. Aber muss man auch sagen, Amnesty International hat eine lange Tradition. Also das ist ja auch so ja viele Jahre Arbeit, die da drinsteckt und die Netzpolitik. Wir haben ja am Anfang erwähnt, das Blog ist zehn Jahre alt, der CCC hat ein bisschen über 30 Jahre. Zwar auf dem Buckel, aber auch ein politischer Akteur. Es ist ja noch nicht so furchtbar lange, weil Computer noch nicht so furchtbar lange vor der Image benutzt werden. Aber ich glaube, das wird sich aufbauen. Florian vergleitet manchmal gerne mit dieser Umweltbewegung, oder?
Ja, ist so ein bisschen Wunschraum. Ich meine, man kann es ja so ein bisschen sehen. Wir sind aktuell an dem Punkt vielleicht da, wo die Umweltbewegung war. So irgendwann hat man halt gemerkt, ja, scheiße, die Atomkraft ist vielleicht auch nicht so sicher, wie immer gesagt wird. Oder jetzt im Netz, wir sind vielleicht doch nicht so unbeobachtet, wie wir uns immer fühlen. Ja, und irgendwann hat es den Leuten halt dann auch gereicht.
Aber glaubt ihr, dass das wirklich passieren kann? Also weil so, also wenn wir, wenn wir, oh Gott, der Vergleich wird bestimmt fürchterlich auf die Füße fallen, aber naja, wenn man sagt, so die Snowden Leaks sind so eine Art Supergau für die Informationsgesellschaft.
Das würde ich total unterschreiben. Es wird ein Paradigmenwechsel einleiten mit dem ganzen Verzeugnis.
Aber hätte der nicht schon kommen müssen?
Ich denke, der ist, der ist im Gange. Ich denke, er passiert gerade. Aber dadurch, dass wird kein, es ist nicht wie bei Fukushima, sozusagen so ein plötzlich Umkippen in der Politik. Ich glaube, dass wird eher ein langsamer Prozess sein wird. Aber er hat schon begonnen. Ich finde, er ist auch schon stark zu beobachten.
Und dann ist aber sozusagen eine Frage, die ich stelle, die, also wenn man jetzt die Umweltbewegung zum Vorbild nimmt, oder vielleicht auch die Friedensbewegung, da gibt es ja ganz klare Ansagen. Da kann man sagen, so keine Atomkraftwerke, keine Atomwaffen, sondern halt irgendwie schwerer zu Flugscharren und Windkrafträder und Solarenergieren lang. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, dass es in der Netzpolitik keine so klaren Handlungsempfehlungen gibt. Es gibt immer sowas wie Netzneutralität, brauchen wir, aber es fällt viel schwerer, dem einzelnen User ganz klar zu sagen, worauf er hinarbeiten soll. Ist das auch ein Problem, dass es zu abstrakt ist?
Es gibt halt ganz, ganz, wir haben uns das auf die Fahnen geschrieben, Fight for Digital Rights ist so das Motto von Netzpolitik und jeder Einzelne kann ganz viel tun und das muss nicht Geld sein. Das kann auch einfach nur fünf Minuten Aufwand sein.
Du hast meine Frage gerade völlig missverstanden, kann das sein? Meine Frage war sozusagen bei Friedens- und Naturbewegung, da kann man sehr klar und sehr eindeutig kommunizieren, was das Ziel ist. Das Ziel ist nämlich keine Atomkraftwerke mehr.
Und da steckt noch eine Vision hinter.
Und vor allen Dingen, man kann das aber auch als einzelner Mensch ganz einfach begreifen, nämlich ich möchte keinen Atomstrom. Sondern ich möchte halt sozusagen, ich möchte Impressen. So und jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich, gerade wenn man so in der Netzpolitik so was sagt, wie verschlüsselte Kommunikation ist super, das ist so ein Ziel, da kann man sich darauf einigen. Aber frag mal einen Beliebigen und dafür würde euch beide hier vielleicht sogar dazuzählen, welche verschlüsselte Lösung ist jetzt die beste? Dann kriegt man halt irgendwie nicht so eine klare Antwort, wie du brauchst ein Windrad, sondern dann gibt es halt ganz verschiedene und noch nichts ist perfekt und so weiter und so fort.
Auch in der etwa Öko-Bewegung, in der Friedensbewegung, in der Umweltbewegung sind natürlich die Antworten nicht einfach in einer komplexen Welt. Aber man kann auch für Netzpolitik natürlich solche Forderungen, hinter denen man sich zusammenscharen kann, sozusagen stellen. Zum Beispiel, nehme ich mal den Beispiel Datenschutz. Man kann als Titel oder als Motto formulieren, ich möchte auch in Zukunft unüberwacht kommunizieren können. Das ist ein einfacher Ziel. So wie ich sagen kann, ich möchte keine Kernenergienutzung oder so. Ich denke, das geht schon. Man kann sagen, bei Netzpolitik möchte ich nicht, dass meine Datenpakete durchgeguckt werden und dann eben priorisiert blockiert oder schneller weitergeleitet werden. Das ist eigentlich schon eine einfache Forderung. Ich gebe zu, dass es Bereiche gibt, wo es komplexer wird. In der IT-Security ist mir das häufiger passiert. Ich habe ja gegenüber der Presse auch oft so diese Klärbärfunktion. Da wird es manchmal komplexer. Aber ich glaube, für viele netzpolitische Bereiche kann man sehr wohl einfache Ziele benennen. Das heißt nicht immer, dass die Lösungen einfach sind, die man dafür anstrebt. Aber das ist in der Umweltbewegung auch nicht so. Und es ist bis heute auch bestritten, wie die richtig sind. Ich finde nicht unbedingt, dass es ein Muss ist. Ein Ziel ist ein Muss. Und dass man eine Vision hat, ist auch ein Muss, glaube ich. Also eine Idee, wie die Zukunft aussehen soll. Und wie sie irgendwie besser ist. Und vielleicht nicht ganz so Kommerz. Lieber Bürger als Konsument so, ja. Aber es muss nicht unbedingt eine trivial einfache Lösung sein.
Ja, aber vielleicht eine, die wenigstens trivial einfach zu verkaufen ist. So, die Sendung ist ja dann auch bald schon wieder vorbei. Ich würde zum Schluss noch von euch wissen wollen, was sind denn so die Themen, also A, was sind die großen Themen, die wir jetzt nicht angesprochen haben, dass wir die wenigstens kurz so mal genannt haben. Und B, was sind denn die großen Themen, die dann demnächst mal anstehen? Was kommt denn dann noch auf uns zu netzpolitisch?
Ja, das schaffen wir aber nicht mehr in 10 Minuten, Florian wird es versuchen mit schneller Sprache.
Muss ich jetzt runterkrattern? Ja, also...
Ja, mit dem Tempo?
Ich muss mal Luft holen, mich ein bisschen wappnen. Ganz akut steht immer noch an, wie wird das denn ausgehen mit dem Überwachungsskandal? Werden wir den aufklären können? Wir hatten, wie ich eben schon mal in der letzten Woche, ein Jahr den NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss und wir sind irgendwie keinen Schritt weiter gefühlt. Also hat der BND mit der NSA kooperiert und der willentlich Daten geliefert. Besteht da sogar eine Kooperation, von der wir nichts wissen sollen. Wird dieser Untersuchungsausschuss da Licht ins Dunkel bringen können? Und wenn ja, selbst wenn das rauskommt, dass das so gewesen ist, was wird das für Folgen haben? Werden sich die Leute dann aufregen und sagen, haben wir eben mal gewusst, so? Das ist eine große Frage. Urheberrecht ist eine ganz konkrete Frage, auf die wir auch schon gesprochen haben. Da steht auf europäischer Ebene die EU-Datenschutzverordnung an.
Was, was, was? Du hast gerade Urheberrecht gesagt und dann Datenschutzverordnung.
Wie hängt das zusammen?
Das ist eine Aufzählung, Markus.
Wir sind schon den nächsten Schritt weiter.
Wir haben nicht so viel Zeit.
Netzhartalität steht auch noch an. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wird auf europäischer Ebene auch ebenfalls entschieden, ob das rechtens ist, ob das in irgendeiner Form in Deutschland doch und in anderen europäischen Ländern umgesetzt werden muss.
Da möchte ich noch keine Nachfrage einfügen, weil ich dachte, da wurde schon entschieden, dass jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die wurde doch in Deutschland abgesagt, weil es auf Europaebene ein Gerichtssortell gab, das sagt er so, nee, so nicht.
Ja, man wartet dann aber noch, wie das da konkret ist und da besteht anscheinend noch Klärungsbetrag, ob das dann in Deutschland doch wieder eingeführt werden kann oder nicht.
Also es gibt eine Menge deutsche Politiker, die können doch einfach deutsche und europäische Urteile ignorieren. Das stelle ich mich nicht so an, Markus.
Du hast doch gerade gesagt, dass du euch die europäische Ebene vorgibt und dann sofort Recht und Gesetz wird.
Ich hätte diese Vorratsentsprechung für Untot. Ja, aber es ist ja nur eine Debatte, die wiederkommt. Also wir haben ja kein Gesetz gesehen. Denn in Wirklichkeit haben doch alle Vorschläge, die jetzt zu kommen, adressieren überhaupt nicht, was die Richter in die Urteile geschrieben haben. Da steht eine Menge interessanter Zeug drin. Man kriegt ja nie konkrete Vorschläge, die sagen immer nur, ja warum Wort dann? Aber wie sie das eigentlich machen wollen gesetzlich und den beiden Urteilen, also dem Bundesverfassungsgericht und dem europäischen Urteil gerecht zu werden, das sagen die nicht mal mehr. Also ich halte das mehr so für Schrammeln. Das ist so untote Schrammeln. In Wirklichkeit ist sie doch tot.
Na, wir sind gespannt.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine Hoffnung von mir. Florian, los, wir haben hier mehr Themen.
Sind wir schon durch oder?
Also ich denke, es werden vor allen Dingen rechtspolitische Probleme sein. Also was wird weiterhin mit den Abmahnungen, die einfach viele Leute, Tiere stören, wie wird das politisch geregelt? Was wird mit der Störerhaftung passieren? Wie ist das mit diesen sogenannten, die ganze Frage, wie wir Kontrolle über unsere Geräte haben? Also was dürfen Hersteller einbauen? Weil in Zukunft vor allen Dingen die sogenannten TPM-Ships, also auch technische Fragen. Das sind manchmal auch eher Verbraucherfragen. Also darf ich mir Software installieren? Oder darf ich jetzt nicht? Solche Fragen. Es wird aber auch umsoweit gehen wie Fair IT. Ach, das sind netzpolitische Themen. Was ist das? Wie ökologisch kann man eigentlich Rechner herstellen? Solche wichtigen Fragen. Wir werden ganz sicher in der Netzpolitik über Big Data, dieses Wirtschaftsschlagwort von einer massenhaften Datenverarbeitung sprechen. Das wird kommen. Wir werden über Algorithmen streiten müssen, die unser Leben bestimmen, weil sie Entscheidungen für uns treffen. Das werden wir auf jeden Fall tun. Wer unter welchen Umständen darf das? Wir werden über Monopole reden, weil es bestimmte Märkte im Bereich von Internet gibt, wo bestimmte Unternehmen ganz hohe Dominanz haben. Klar, da werden unglaublich viele Streitthemen sein. Wir werden auch wieder, wenn die Zukunft ein bisschen weiter geht über Online-Wahlsysteme, das kommt doch wieder, vielleicht in fünf Jahren oder so. Ich glaube, uns werden die Themen auf jeden Fall nicht ausgehen. Und wir werden ganz sicher über allem, weil das die Basis sein wird, über sehr viel IT-Security reden müssen. Also die Sicherheit in Netzen, in Software, in Briebsystemen, das wird so ein begleitendes Thema immer sein. Also wir haben spannende Themen, oder?
Aber wird das dann sozusagen eine politische Diskussion sein? Oder wird das dann auch Hand in Hand gehen, wie das da auf Wahlcomputern, Schach gespielt wird oder ähnliche lustige Dinge?
Also in Deutschland ist der Markt, der ist ein Markt aus Sicht der Anbieter, der ist erstmal tot, weil wir ein deutliches Urteil aus Kartsrohr haben. Wir haben Vorgaben, die gemacht wurden.
Ich meinte generell, weil du sagst, IT-Security ist so ein großes Thema, ist Netzpolitik, wird sich das immer weiter zu einer abstrakten Diskussion entwickeln oder wird auch der praktische Hack, der Spaß am Gerät, da noch eine Rolle spielen?
Na ja, gut, im CCC spielt natürlich so ein praktischer Hack, das sind die Wahlkapitale, das sind ja ein Beispiel, oder der Schatz Trojaner oder so, wird weiterhin eine Rolle spielen. Ich glaube, die politische Diskussion, die läuft natürlich in der Regel ein bisschen anders. Klar kann man, wenn man so einen großen Hack hat, die beim Schatz Trojaner, kann man auch politisch daran Forderungen knüpfen. Aber die klassischen netzpolitischen Debatten sind eher so Marathonläufe, wo man sich einfach jahrelang streitet, immer wieder versucht, Sachargumente anzubringen und so weiter. Und auch teilweise so Lobby-Sachen einfach aufzudecken und eben diese Gegenöffentlichkeit herzustellen. Ich glaube, das hat auch mit Zielen zu tun. Also warum nützt du dich für bestimmte netzpolitische Sachen?
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade noch fragen. Es gibt diese riesige Palette, ihr seid jetzt aber zwei Leute, Constanze Kurz und Florian Gilberg. Und ich würde von jedem von euch noch ganz kurz wissen, was ist das eine Thema, was auf eurer nächsten Agenda steht? Florian?
Was drauf steht und was drauf stand und auch noch stehen wird, ist Überwachung definitiv. Wie können wir uns schützen? Was können wir machen, um global Überwachung zu verhindern? Und zwar sowohl von Staaten als auch von Konzernen, die uns ausspionieren, die Profile über uns anlegen, wo wir fast überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr drüber haben und das uns auch noch in 10, 20 Jahren verfolgen wird. Man sagt so schön, alles, was du jemals gegoogelt hast, wird gegen dich verwendet werden. Das birgt enormes Gefahrenpotenzial.
Constanze? Ich könnte nicht ein Thema sagen, weil ich einfach, wenn man für einen Verein spricht, mich immer mit vielen Themen beschäftige. Aber es gibt natürlich ein Thema, wo ich besonders viel Herzblut drin habe und was mich derzeit sehr interessiert auf mehreren Ebenen. Das sind für mich Drohnen. Und zwar vom Militär bis zu Kleinstdrohnen und Spielzeugen. Mich interessiert diese Technik derzeit sehr. Wohin sie sich entwickelt, ich denke da gerne über Technikfolgenabschätzung nach. Da habe ich den Eindruck, mich auch engagieren zu müssen. Aber ich könnte nicht sagen, dass ich mich auf ein Thema stürze und nicht gehe.
Na gut, es gibt ja genug zu tun. Wir haben in den letzten zwei Stunden reichhaltig versucht zu erklären, was Netzpolitik ist und was auch ihr oder wofür ihr euch da interessieren könntet. Wenn ihr es noch mal ganz genau nachhören wollt, der Podcast zu dieser Sendung wird im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de erscheinen und dann sicherlich später auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de und Constanze macht aufgeregte Gesten. Was ist denn los?
Unbedingt müssen wir noch darauf hinweisen, dass ihr klicken müsst auf events.ccc.de denn wir werden diesen Sommer ein Camp haben. Und kürzlich ist eine Hacker-Truppe zur Besichtigung gefahren, hat sich Gelände angeguckt.
Also wer sich informieren will, events.ccc.de Wird im Sommer ein Camp stattfinden, das heißt Zelte und Hacker, alles auf einem Haufen. Draußen und nackt. Wir beenden die Sendung an dieser Stelle und verweisen auf die angegebenen Webseiten und wünschen euch dabei viel Spaß. Das Chaosradio gibt es nächsten Monat nicht hier auf Fritz, sondern im Chaos Computer Club Berlin live in der Marienstraße 11 vor Ort. Mit Bild und Tonik könnt ihr gerne vorbeikommen, wenn ihr wollt. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight mit Henrik Schröder. Dabei wünsche ich euch viel Spaß. Vielen Dank, Constanze Kurz und Florian Gilberg. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich sage nur noch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Pack-ups.